one is unable to use the stairs but they
please allow others to exit the run for
they go to the farm escape door where
they can be given assistance assembly
point will be in a couple carlock have a
side of the Civic sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to
building until given permission to do so
by council staff now I have two
apologies for absence from this is Linda
Walker and councillor Jamie burst and
other and the others then non been
members attending the minutes of the
meeting held on the second of October
2014 is it your wish the rhizome
sideways as a true copy okay I got the
time and are there any declarations of
interest in that case before we go on to
the fight and five on the agenda just in
the wrong
surfing words to talk about the that the
changeover which means that he is here
and as the Lord is here it has as well
yes thank you children don't keep it
fairly fairly short son resident to be
some residents members in rather will be
much more aware analysis to the
situation there has been a redesign of
the council which is led to changing the
management structure at the top is still
the chief exec under hidden there are
two directors of which I on the other is
short squatted and under in the third
tier under that is and nine currently
from annoying assistant directors a web
page with titles one of which is Angela
law SAT there who is the assistant
director for the legal and with that
role is a monitoring officer all and it
used to be Albert Albert will have
departed and I think the date is next
week monday and though things thank you
so Angela will officially be designated
monitoring officer from from that day so
you say okay there's a new role for her
my my reason for being here today is not
just them to support other assistant
director doesn't where necessary if I
can I've had some experience obviously
if the monitoring officer side of things
and other deputy
before under Albert in the interim as
andrew is monitoring officer she can
designate a deputy the matron officer it
may be that she dedicates me that I need
to clear it until for the women may be
further changes with the personnel
department web latency so that's really
it from from where I stand if analysis
Jim thank you very much and also as this
is Angela's first standards meeting
could I ask the independent members to
introduce themselves all the places are
on think you probably know the district
council members yes I hope that
privately told you and the parish I'm
sorry this outside councillor Debbie
constable parish member cal soleski
bingo perishing stanchion bottom thank
you ok Tony returning now to change
agenda we have only one item five
do you want to same thing switch and
this home obviously business / pool that
comes in and we lost two members to
training training sessions we share and
simply lgo that all government
association is wrong Natalie learning
program which is free to the district
councils I think Michelle's can find out
for they that can be mobbed up parish
councils and we'll be in touch with the
clocks on mustn't chairman of the page
5.5 an important recommendations is to
receive members tenants at training
sessions to endorse proposals of the
learning program and to and whether you
agree for that LGA elearning to be
rolled out you're probably going to that
mr. Chairman I just after some
clarification legislation items in or
digital rules thank you and Anton
problem is wheeled 2.3 in greedily
differently opportunities provided by
this councils learning a development
program women are able to take advantage
of two member budget away days in
october 2014 in january 2050 and the
annual member to have plenty types of
placing a total team and a little
concerned that this week condom be in a
report on remember learning
and the budget away days as an English
ation to participate it is not learning
at the development opportunity and this
body by its inclusion it in the report
it would imply it it is so i'll be like
it noted that this is not other members
learning and developing place or if you
don't wish to note it than you add like
it noted that i object the implication
the titties learning development budget
or my toes my throne so not many members
to have clarification it's fair comment
is my ears so we can note that you'd bet
they've been amendments minuted yeah
thank you thank you accepted oh yeah
Thank You Terry my doctor came back 30
item 6.1 i think is what happens to
perish campus we've ever least of the
attendances bind and RDC members but
what sort of take up has that been on
the parishes has it been successful with
the training that they be able to to
felt an opportunity off and if not what
do we need to do to encourage them to
take better training particularly on
planning matters
Jamie I think I'm passionate we rolled
up stands and code of conduct training
I'm not sure that we roll out we invited
the parish's as well to attend the
safeguarding and the antisocial behavior
training this year but and with those
are free of challenge to the parish's
but we charge for what the calls to
charges included pounds he was very to
toady and they don't get invited
specifically to attend to plenary
session come back on the agenda am I
correct in believing that there are
additional planning training
specifically for parishes to attend
sometimes and how many of those have
occurred and how much take off
mississippi and i think fairly good to
take up when Sean spat in his random but
he runs those completely independently
to do this training program and it's not
specifically said okay I just think it
might be useful for us to know that as
to have that side of things is working
go yeah I'm just answering the parish's
be another parish many many years a few
years ago but we're planning is
concerned they do have a planning
committee we use for they go through
what happens in planning I just threw
you Jim and I wonder whether we can ask
obviously got the Parish Council on here
for it whether we can ask thing what the
situation is with a train sided with
regards to your parish council go wrong
train is it because of the fees that he
charged or is it because you feel that
is it's not adequate or you don't need
the counselors to go on these courses
well I can reply from the point of view
of hockley I'm not on banging I must
have looked never have been but I know
there's a soak been very close contact
when i'm sean has been over several
times to cool and i do believe our
chairman of planning there were recently
some planning changes over the last year
or so did attend courses here an Archon
our chairman of the council and i
believe some of the planning members so
but they are very enthusiastic planning
because it's such a minefield but when
it comes to things like safeguarding
children etc it's not really the area of
parish councils is it might be in their
private lives that have volume as
governor's etc but it's not going to be
something i think that they're going to
particularly want to come to the
district council for the training
licensing doesn't come under parish
councils does it so not going to come to
this i have been to come a few of your
courses here as a member of this
committee to monitor and as a parish
so from several things up but and I
thought though very good you do actually
mention in the report somewhere about
dealing with difficult people somebody
said that's what they could would like
or something actually Essex Association
local councils is doing it next week and
I think another parish councils would be
saying that people thank you I shouldn't
do it slightly different to hockley all
the parish councillors are on their
planning committee and so therefore form
our point of view at a fee especially I
think the ones that Sean does
specifically for parishes which are very
good insofar as they are the very bottom
basics as to I understand how much
import courage from hanging up the steps
are they are good but I feel what
they're being specifically put on four
parishes they could be offered free of
charge oh you think the year the ones
that show usually inhibition from it's
certainly obviously from a student's
point of view if it's everyone attending
and do know from talking to other parish
chairman that they also subject to the
payment particularly the ones that are
specifically put on four parishes and
don't have because I decide that they're
geared up totally different level to the
members training and they are good for
parish councils to understand what they
can and can't and check to the material
considerations etc etc by the eve that
point you can
Oh missed you yes I would support that
view because I'm the representative for
Roger District Council on the Rockford
hundred an every meeting of cross 100
they do ever got me regards to the cost
of the and the training that Roger
district council charged parishes so I
think it's important as cancer steptoe
raised the point as to how much snow
there is it was from the parishes and
respect about training that's a very
important point a respective planning
and what anything that we have to charge
for the thing is it's um Sean mouse
director he's not God's specifically
just for planning in the area and we
have a good assistant director for
planning personalized but the bottom oh
I usually charge we make for the
parishes in Cedars of parishes as a
barrier for them to come to our training
sessions mr. Chen could be perhaps asked
for some information list so that we can
fault because I got so so so much oh
bring you in a second picture I just
really to agree with what's being said I
know with my own particular parish they
would like to attend but it's not
something that they've got a
particularly large platform and if there
wasn't any charges that they would there
would be more attendance on them they
know they recognized I did he is an
important factor and he's becoming more
important as time goes on but they feel
that there is this
as you mention i think it's something we
need to really look at and conceived and
I think so we are so important for the
parishes because of the role they're
taking far more rolling ticketing
planning matters so is it your your
suggestion we consider not approaching
their junk I personally yes I but I
personally suggest not having the charge
to encourage the Pharisees as the
counselor said the some of the other
courses which not really relevant
perishes but certainly ones like the
planning I think I'm very relevant I'm
very important and I think you need to
get as many of the parish councils
there'd be positive so i would i would
suggest not imagine a chance i want to
make that a form with your pose it's all
five how second one should i come back
on that to you and I wanted it from in
order as well oh you make any decisions
I think we should all be heard yeah okay
okay book we've got a proposal so there
to speak to that first they speaking to
the proposal I'm quite happy to speak
against them you can speak of your baby
I kinda did I have you down to speak
next thank you so if you're speaking I
think we're rushing into this I think we
need the information no one seems to
know how many courses are available to
the parish how many courses have been
offered free of charge how many courses
have been offered at a charge and how
many have been attended I think that
seemed to be information we want to know
before we can make a credit decision
also what I said that the parishes have
pressure on their budgets so do we as a
district handsome and one of the other
aspects if you recall going back to
other standards meetings that why we
didn't open it to the parishes was
because we can have the space we hardly
have the space on planning to get our
own members in on
times so that there's lots of things to
consider rather than just the price
there's whether or not what's been
happening in the past we need to know
that to go forward and then if it's
decided that perhaps that should be
opened up that the decision can be made
with information at the moment we
rushing in to a decision on no basis
whatsoever ever other than the fact that
the parishes don't might pay for it
we've got those statistics no
information to thank you mr. chair I
actually would virtually agreed word for
word with Christine I know unusual
Christine that we agree on something the
thing is we put a feeling these and I
distinctly remember when it happened
because when the parish is going for
trading to Braintree or wherever they go
it's far more expensive than 40 pound
far more expensive so for them to
sectors go over there all the time you
know not afford it up in his vizarana an
order thing to say and I think
Christine's right we too have a huge
constraints all right we've done the
redesign and everything else that we've
done but we still have constraints okay
little check so carol was so platings
Wilson I think I'm fun I didn't have you
do that's right I I grieve it Mike and
could I just say I can't remember but I
remember when we had a meeting of quite
a few months ago or a year or so ago
that we did say that we were charged in
the parishes on certain things I didn't
quite answer was plain or not my aspect
is obviously I agree with what their the
caps are saying but it may well be
something to think on but because plan
is a big issue with in boxford it may be
something to consider that you only you
don't charge with the planning but you
charge for the other training courses
because I think we need to get the
parishes involved we need to get the
deal
parish councillors involved in any of
these planning issues I know they had
their own meetings and they discussed
these planning's plans that come up and
they put forward ideas or yes or knows
but I feel that they need to get more
involved in maybe it might be an aspect
of not charging particularly for the
plan the planning training but only for
the other training courses they come in
and I understand what others are saying
here with regards yes in this particular
room it is quite crowded but there's no
reason why we couldn't use the chamber
room downstairs the cost towards the
district if we are already running the
cause that I don't think there will be
any additional cost if the parish
councillors came along to that
particular point in time so if the
coffee's on named the coffee comes to be
expedient but if we use the chamber the
larger room and the parachutes were
there where is the extra cost to the
district on their faces I don't quite
understand that and as Carol says it is
so important that the parishes do
understand so I've got concerns we can
simply use another room a lot of series
saw you first I think I think there was
the first time I think we're going to
say the same and we never did it in the
first instance because if oh let's make
loads of money for me what we did and I
just did to remember when it happened
was why should we give them free when
they they're not free anywhere else at
all I'm not against or Carol is saying
about let's give them the planning one
scripture but I think Christine's right
we need some more information on this
Thank You mr. chair
I'm finally going indoor sports say that
I've taken the point that we could use
the council payment but we can't because
if you can notice how the training has
developed and evolved over time it's
done in group sessions you can't do that
in the council chamber what your then
doing is inhibiting the type of training
that we're getting because you're
extending it now I've got no strong
feeling one way or the other of whether
we should or shouldn't charge the
parishes what I do have a strong feeling
about is that we shouldn't blindly make
a decision with that information and I
think we would be wrong to do that I
think what we need to do is to get that
information have a look at what's being
done in the past have a look at the
attendants have a look at the
challenging find out perhaps what could
have been done and what we can do
without compromising the training that
we have for our members which surely
must take a priority Jennifer come back
perhaps picking up on those points I
commend my proposal is that we and we
write the parish's we ask the parachutes
for their opinion we take into account
the rockford hundred have got to say I
mean and we also look at the data that
we have got available and see what see
how it has been painting it perhaps
that's the way to go so it is getting
very we need to get the data first yes I
think we need to have the views from
everybody in it from the parishes watch
the hundred as counsel here is so
representing us in rocks 100 and I think
we need to take all of those using to
kill you sorry um it's got nothing to do
with those people we did this for a
reason without any shadow of a doubt we
did it to make an income it is not you
will not write one of those people they
go yeah I'm quite happy
thank you very much they don't say no I
don't want to play but they're quite
happily pay 60 70 plus pound to go to
braintree for the day I just think this
makes much more looking at I'm
definitely was crispy clean this I don't
think was actually two to make some
money wrong yes it was it's a punch it
always was maybe I'll be rather i think
it was to reflect the fact that it costs
us money yes and therefore they should
share in that in that expensive they're
going to share indeed triangle I think I
I accept comes to the same things but
they it was there well I would bet
anything that you rang but none of them
will say yes we're quite happy to pay
just that before what we which are
watched there weren't that many of them
that used to come to planning anyway if
you look back at figures and this is
what I think we should do we should look
at this we shouldn't make any decisions
and I I think we should give her the
figures and the attendance of before we
cast and after we charge because I can
distinctly remember that not many Pasha
members to come to planning
yes I really have a memory of a
conversation about a year ago discussion
here about a year ago more is what how
can we encourage parish councils to come
and I think my response then was well
the ones who want to come do come but
the vast majority of parish councillors
are not as interested or perhaps as
motivated as a district councillor and
do not want to come I don't know about
the other councils but there is a budget
at hockley the same people will turn up
to the same courses we've probably all
done with several times I think Carol
knows have hadn't been a hotly cancer at
one time you cannot and I said it's
aimed at time I think you can take a
horse to water you can't make it
dredging so I think you do need
statistics but I know interesting to
find out how many of people thing to all
of them and how many thing to know is
because we have the report Ron and
district couch was attending I'm not
American and it was how can we get them
to come because it would you know if
they pay then it will go towards
covering the charge but our own members
and the discussion of our school you
know how can we motivate them and I said
the same thing you'll get a few as you
always do Who are very keen to learn the
rest who are happy being houses and just
having that community that way I've had
little interesting planning because and
I mean everything because we have
mittee I'm never been interested in
planning but when it comes to open
spaces well I turn up to him oh yes
chairman can we then can we then go
forward on this and put it on an agenda
for later on and and in the meantime
probably get as you say you want all
these statistics to do with this and
maybe we've never discussion in and take
it forward from their face can I put on
current secondary okapi seiko proposing
that we get the information not from the
parishes we know what the person says I
want we don't get confused about what
proposals we've got on the table I've
got one on our own now would you be
happy to amend your proposal to reflect
what yes I'm happy to do that but the
only thing I would like to know from the
parishes is simple people are mentioned
about the parishes going to Brighton is
to have some idea of actually how many
of those perc's do it eight I don't
think it's as big a number as we think
you did might be I think you'll be
surprised I made its price [ __ ] I
speak for the Paris trees down my entire
district yes I know it wasn't bring a
true yes that's the question what is
their budget and how much do they spend
on courses i really i think you turning
first question yes I think we asked a
simple question when they get the
information and we should have in-house
our own statistics well it's for
Michelle benefit can be been clear as to
what information so it is suggested that
we gotta come back to me I think we were
just discussing planning we're not
discussing the other courses are we
planning so we want to find out if room
there for many sausages you know would
there only offered on an ad hoc basis
okay
shawn has the capacity that's what's
been done in the past but we've got
nothing specific planned anyway should I
come back with a cuz i don't think the
quarters of the guys go to in dumbo to
do a plan you need to do with other am I
right or am I elastic mother had my
class chairmanship trained in which i
think it's done here as well he'll
handle i'd like to withdraw his proposed
i'm happy to do that protem and that we
asked michelle to come back with this
information yet yeah okay everybody you
go down with you I've realized nobody
knows hold on yes giving the statistics
etc or not such a turn and then
virtually deferred further discussion on
it until the next meeting by which time
hopefully we will have the incarnation
of statistics and we'll be able to
approach it all specifically yeah you
can't just that is to do with planning
is it not to do then here is everything
oh she genuinely cares I thought we just
play sorry should be Jenny it should be
genuinely with a particular she's on the
land possess that's clearly the most
important she lies but I just say could
be asked four parishes what their budget
is and how much they spend out some
other buddies say because that would
give us information that we don't have
and then we can go forward and look at
it and see what we can do to assist it's
not unreasonable we should also that
it's probably there can see I've also
include asking rother country as well
because they represent them they do ya
thang kind of budget
they all good thing when I something out
of it come on do you have your hand up
sure I want their just a mention regards
to Roger handle the next meeting of the
rocks are losing on 23rd with good life
any other point to raise on item from
I'm not sure if I James oh yeah it's a
very simple one motion is a very simple
answer but here we are discussing
charges to their parishes and a charge
that was a great thing other than parity
and then we've offered one to a
neighboring Authority free of charge I
think I know the answers but I would
like to ask the question what to go 72.0
2007 thanks oh yeah yeah
that doubles lizard there was very
little to take up by our counselors and
so it was on the Monday before the
course was on the Thursday and so we
couldn't really charge because it was so
close to the actual time of the calls so
the roads right to him he made the
decision mr. Jim before manhood okay so
they just seemed a little odd to me that
we have a policy that is then go from
following that many cinemas directly
contacting but I cannot understand the
logic behind ya fire I suppose EKG there
was even cost us any more than a street
fair because it was it was going to cost
have a cost airman and there was little
takeout from district answers then it
might as well be utilized
pragmatism it's jeff Gemma through you
chairman would it would it had a cost
element if we canceled it if it wasn't
sorry if there was enough people
attending to people entertained it's
gonna cost 200 quid would it cost us
nothing or 50 pound pretty canceling
that I don't know that openly give you a
cancellation fee be able to give
cancellation fees we normally hire a
trainer and then we're clear come for
you to more usually to go a training
course they always have a cancellation
fee on anything if you cancel within 24
hours 7 days five days to it or whatever
maybe there's something to look at again
well maybe we could if I may suggest
express concern that it was off free of
charge to naval authorities without any
consideration be made the possibility of
cancelling if there was insufficient
take up
yeah good that wasn't me i don't think i
will just do lady i do ladies first Jill
okay it's just a quickie with that
subtle which is talking about it may
well be that we live in advance quite a
long way in advance when these courses
are happening if there is the take-up
surely again we know quite a long way in
advance would it not have been a good
idea if we did have to pay a
cancellation fee to have gone back to
members and said that we've got pair
cancellation fee are you sure there
isn't anybody else that wants to come
because I think a lot of people would
have in that case rather than pay a fee
just a thought so so time factor may be
going on buddy oh well I don't see how
that could be as we know Lane advance of
this training simply why I feel this may
be a dangerous question two hours but
although this was offered to neighboring
and District Council's for the buffets
and parishes said it was diagnosed I
don't know I thank mr. chairman and
happy asked for statistics inspectors
the other as we've talked about because
the parishes do we have any statistics
now take it that this one has only
recently been agreeing about the 45
pounds doing any statistics regards the
take-up of the people from here side
bodies who might be who have taken it
taken up the other as we've had that a
long time it's not a new object occurs
it's not that new well why it was great
in the 21st of Tober no charge even
their HR 2309 sony yes although it was
just increased oh there is okay i played
a pretty much game it doesn't deter from
the fact that we need to again
statistics as to how much is how much do
they've taken up negligible anyway but I
confinement yeah it's never been here to
do visitor thank you and again we're
trying to resolve something without
information we're saying could we've
cancelled it would have been a
cancellation challenge can we perhaps
find out obviously if its internal the
cancellation cost is minimal it's just
distracting but can we not find out when
we engage that's I bought it if there is
a cancellation of thing what time I
really should we should know this what
what time factors required and then as
cancelled in the skill set if we're
getting close that figure where the--
the actual event is not viable then we
go out and say look it's not viable
unless we get X number of extra painful
it will be cancelled but we need that
information we can't say or used to put
ideas can sort it's a good idea to press
no Rick frame doojoon information was
obtained so no I'm not talking about
historically i think we need going
forward as well I mean I was just born
I've just wondering whether think that
it had been austere and when he was
making a bit of tape no I agree anything
to gain by going over he's storing down
and round but I do think that going
forward we need to know what contracts
were agreeing to what their liabilities
are under them and what's implication of
those liabilities at the moment we don't
see tons of obvious so will that be
agreed yeah yes Anu thank you okay
in other questions observations voice to
raise we have not much as those personal
recommendations I will take them
individually first recommendation is to
receive a summary of members attendance
at training sessions your municipal year
2014-15 as set out in paragraph 2 1 that
agreed particularly to endorsing
proposals for the member learning and
development program for 2015-16 SLT set
out in paragraphs for 14 12 let agreed
agreed
now the third recommendation either
working with anything you want to raise
on this before we go straight to bring
is confirmation yes when it says school
counselors is that to all councilors
including parishes or is it just our DC
counselors know each other I think we
were going to find Michelle's find out
why that was open to pow houses as well
yeah yeah we knew we need to check that
yessir but probably like to include
representatives over the years well
here's a dentist I don't think that
involves any additional cost i got men
well i think that involved any time any
chance it's the logo we've got info i
think if you're already a it's a member
of the LG which I stand up trash
counselors are it's free it's free but
what Michelle could do is find out what
it's open to perish mass and then we
load that back to the house clocks and
then they can arrange the implants for
their members the only observation I
purple mrs. I couldn't you Thomas this
we use I could utilize this I would not
be able to have this so oh these modules
that we're being offered to us if we
can't use them on the e-learning courses
is there an opportunity for counselors
to have them in another format that that
wouldn't be within because these are
courses these elusive by the LGN cells
we have no control of these horses
it is an issue with IT or was issued
because we are inside a room for you
here and wish you wouldn't be principal
okay but I thought you we don't have any
control these courses did they are free
course is set by the LGA okay there's no
that sounds question thinking I'd like
to know exactly how they work I've done
elearning courses myself in the past and
would have got halfway through and so
I'll blow this you know it's something
out among monitor these to see they
actually get to the end is it at the
bigotry first of all are all the counts
is going to have to do then is somebody
going to monitor them to make sure they
get to the end and though they give the
certificate at the end or something
somebody told or is it just going to be
it's a rather nice idea it's here and
you can do it if you want in which case
you might as well save our money I think
at least as far i know it's free yes I
will find out for the parish councils
but it's not bigotry I'm talking about
Rochford as much as anything you know
these courses are very good tread
trainers bringing out yes they're a good
idea but are they actually utilized once
they're in the system properly you know
does anybody know that some has somebody
started it they actually finished it and
got benefit from its it it's not
obligatory it's not really cause channel
for us to monitor is if it's at all
that's there for members should they
wish to use it really you know you're
not gonna be test iPad well as I
understand there's no test at the end of
it I'm going to be more generally for
your TF you know it's closer so I don't
you go back to difficult i'm using that
to its really like i said it's just all
your information just refreshes and
you're not
hofstra the other is no cost attached to
it or no cost no cost at all I mean we
wouldn't want to it's not at all it's
not you know it's not it's not our
program we saw we couldn't control it
anyway but it's there should you wish to
use it if it is available for the
parishes I know the district councils
will have long ones for words like but
I'm sure I mean you shell could probably
find out any information from the LGA
itself and pass it on to your clients
I'm not thinking so much about the
parish councils I'll just thinking of
human nature so I've faces in a coffee
of a few min nature I thought you
disliked them and it sold out my
district council week yeah we're just
let you know that is there is this
powder as long as you know to not check
if nobody takes about have these
interesting it's not course it is but
because very and I think area showing
you so we're not alone in this out we're
just in falling yeah so really that they
find the recommendation margin three is
slightly miss word because we never
owned them to if we could put informed
regarding the rollout I'd be quite happy
with it it sounds as if we're rolling it
out as if we're taking charge of this
and we're not sorry we're just
facilitating something for the LG right
I mean chairman then I come through you
I agree why is it unlimited I is it on
the agenda I'm to do with us why is it
only who is the training tool as well
for you coast is to provide is it
raining too it must be a cost to ask
we've talked about traded now there's
Anna Costner we clear this because
because were members of the LGA they do
a lot of this sort of stuff and don't
charge I understand that but it just
seems a bit strange that it's sort of
saying saying if you want to do it do it
you know we do it don't do it no it's
amazing always been like that
without this sort of thing available
before I'm embarrassed I just perhaps
suggest we change the words roll out to
encourage yeah yes sir take Oh she'd be
reason you would everyone okay with that
what to advise members or to advance i
think take a shuttle something out oh I
to judge I don't like perish because it
is i'm very happy well I'd say this will
do is well take out rolled out and
advise members so the third
recommendation is whether to advise
members of the LGA e-learning courses as
set out in paragraphs 5 125 for tourism
ok mission so with that being the last
item close reading of 2014 thank you
very much for your attendance
you